hello and welcome to the new world
review I'm crying I'm waifu and i'm here
to take you on a journey through space
and time we're going to see through what
was what is what will be what never was
what couldn't be what could be if only i
were allowed to use the secret words
secret words look into my eyes and put
your thumb up now put your thumb down
now put your thumb up and shake it all
around but specifically use your thumb
to click on the subscribe button while I
provide grand spoilers
[Music]
this time it's okay by friends it's okay
if I you spoilers because you won't
remember any of this happen you will
forget whatever happens in this hello
and welcome to the new world review
today we're discussing episodes 35 and
36 of some anime episode 35
welcome to Schwing part 2 this episode
was quite disturbing it's not actually
called Schwing part 2 but that's what
I'm calling it this episode was quite
disturbing and though I spent some time
discussing hisoka's pedophilic
appearance last episode maybe we need to
return to it briefly pedophilia as it
appears in the Diagnostic and
Statistical Manual fifth edition
specifies a sexual interest in children
I would again suggest that if it were an
adult who held the potential to grow
into a powerful combatant his sokka's
Schwing would be very much in their
direction we could go so far as to say
that this is almost certainly the case
actually because his ogre doesn't swing
for kill why and you'd think that if it
was such a simple thing
Peter philia that is he would or should
but he has his sights set on gone and
that's particularly important his
orgasmic reaction to gone is when God
shows his intent to win when he shows
his power and his potential it's not a
response to gone at all really but to
the fact that his power isn't fully
developed and Hisoka can see that one
day it will be perhaps a fight among
equals it seems that what Hisoka wants
is a fight with someone he could lose to
and he has his sights set on gone it
also seems that he's willing to wait at
a relative distance forgone to develop
into a better fighter and that more than
anything shows he's not actually a
pedophile he's not actually grooming
gone he's willing to wait forgotten to
experience the world and experience life
before he approaches again before he
takes on gone in what his Sokka assumes
would be his final form to Hisoka
it's about finding his perfect opposite
which he outwardly states he's a
transmuter and gone is a simpleton
I mean enhancer his perfect opposite
should be the perfect balance for him
their relationship could be intimate not
in the sexual sense but in the sense
that they're well matched to fight to
the death and perhaps that's what Hisoka
wants a fight to the death with an
actual chance of dying that's what he
seems to say and this is why I love
Hisoka he's an incredibly complex
character and we seem to have touched on
so many of his complexities in so little
time
the fact that he named his Bungie gum
elastic love and placed it like a kiss
on Dawn's face the fact that such a name
came from a gun he used to chew as a boy
suggests that perhaps he learned how to
use men at a young age and named it that
because that's where the inspiration
came from his use of it personality
traits to understand men uses is
fantastic and was so quickly understood
in a way that I struggled to understand
the types otherwise as someone who
thinks in psychology I was grateful for
that comparison and that information
dump speaking of information dump we've
had a lot of law handed to us over the
last few episodes and they've held
varying degrees of interest to me it was
great seeing his Sokka explained to GaN
those areas where he needed more
experience and more learning it was
fantastic to see GaN trying to take on
that information and interesting to see
his so cannot allow him time to really
find his feet he pushed him and gone
learned from that as much as from the
actual information given that's
something I'm loving about gone as a
character we've seen that when he has
time to think things through he can find
an answer Hisoka has seen that too and
he decided instead to teach gone what
happened in the real world if he took
too long to answer and make decisions
gone now needs to learn to act and react
much more quickly if he's going to
succeed in the long run as to law
finding out that there were two kinds of
point marking and being given the
information that the referee wanted to
keep going alive as much as his Sokka
did was interesting but wait who was
this guy silver and sparkly guy who is
he done is something where did he come
from why was he here he seemed to get in
and out fairly quickly and he only
appeared for the one moment maybe he'll
turn up somewhere else it's not like
hunter hunter to give us a new character
then not immediately give us more
information as to who they are in their
purpose what it does say I suppose is
that God and his focus fight was being
watched by much more than just the
standard audience in fact was that kill
was father it's the closest I can come
to someone who has looked like that and
I'm only really thinking about that now
that's awkward
why would kill wise father be at guns
fire if I'm wrong it's okay because he
was there for all of a minute but why
and who as to the fight itself it was
great seeing gone beginning to be able
to keep up with his Sokka it was great
to see his hocus power but that he very
clearly measured it out his oak and
never went all out in that fight gone
landed some hits and that was satisfying
but his Sokka was never in any real
danger it's interesting because I also
see the potential hisoka's talking about
gone managed to break in Loomis armor
the end of the previous arc even before
all this and the increased strength as a
result of nen Gaughan was strong and
he's becoming stronger he's still not as
strong as Hisoka he landed that hit and
so he can claim his hunter exam pass and
visit home but the fear he feels around
his Sokka is still very clearly there
and probably always will be Don's
motivation remains the same becomes
strong enough to beat Hisoka in a fight
at this point they have a lot of history
together and I expect that he and his
Sokka are going to meet at the end of
each arc has gone grows with Hisoka
pointing out another area forgotten to
gain experience in each time leaving my
love Hisoka alone for now there was a
beautiful end of art feeling to the soft
purples and blues and fountain at the
end of the episode after the stark an
harsh lights of the arena to switch to
the car and the admittance of wing that
he has nothing more to teach gone I
pride again just for a minute the beauty
of that scene after the quick paced and
brutality if the previous one was
well-timed
and the fact that we didn't go straight
there we went to a discussion of how the
referee was a technical one so that we
as an audience understood that the
referee was trying to be kind in their
adjudication took us from brutality to
kindness to softness and the combination
was now that he's a hunter he can go
home to meto and share what his learn
which puts us into an interesting place
to start episode 36 episode 36 there
were some really beautiful moments in
this episode moments that reminded me
that as much as I have problems with
gone as a functioning member of society
it's very clear that he and Kilwa are in
fact children it was great to see Kahn
showing Kahn who's gone
it was great to see God showing kilwa
around his home and for Kela it was
fantastic for him to see what a loving
ordinary home looks like it was very
clear immediately that no matter how
many fights they engage in no matter how
big and strong they get mito has more
runnin and nnn than both of them and mmm
she's a dangerous powerhouse but she's
dangerous because Gahan cares about her
and that's very clear and evident the
relationship between gone and Mito is
beautiful and is visible in the way
Gahan talks to her but also in the way
he talks about her actually this entire
episode was a reminder that there are
soft loving feelings in these characters
and that all of the fighting and danger
of the series is set against a backdrop
of love and care the Artemis episode was
phenomenally framed and drawn from the
angles used to show kill while walking
uphill alone to the scene of gang
rescuing Mito as she sat in a giant tree
to the starry night has gone asked
Kilauea to go steady and kill I looked
away bashfully speaking of gone asking
to go steady this beautiful quiet scene
is the first in which Kela actually
opens up to someone anyone it's the
first time we've seen Kela at all
vulnerable around anyone no sooner are
his words out of his mouth than he seems
to regret them but gone immediately
validates his thoughts and feelings it's
the first time the two have really sat
down and discussed the future the first
time they've discussed anything besides
getting stronger or combat or beating
others down for the first time in this
episode we get to see the people rather
than the superheroes and frankly this
was well overdue and very well done some
of the wonderful narration of this
episode was in the way it shifted point
of view very close to the beginning of
the episode we saw the world through
Kiowas eyes as he began to eat and
realize that this particular family has
other rules that Gahan doesn't follow
when he's away from home Gahan slips
easily back into routines he was raised
on Kiawah has to learn them he's never
given thanks he's probably never had a
pleasant family meal to come from the
world of trauma and difficulty where all
he has ever learned is to harm and win
and control to this world where the aim
is to share and engage and soothe he'll
are sleeping safely in a bed while Gahan
finds out about his father is perhaps
the only set of frames you need to
understand the energy of this episode
the music of this episode was
spectacularly in line with the quality
as well with soft cello gathering with
those soft background blues of Mito
crying to be honest it wasn't just me
crying during that scene I'm crying a
lot recently apparently the meeting of
art music and wistfulness of tone was
fantastic and I laughed and cried a
goodly number of times which is exactly
what I want from media icons you Mito
guns aren't and the only mother he's
ever had standing there behind a rock
will stay with me as one of the most
beautiful frames in this series I think
especially since it's the open and
plainness with which God says he can't
ask about his mum that's really a punch
in the gut we see in that moment that
beside kilwa God really does care about
Mito not asking about his mother because
to all intents and purposes she is his
mother and he doesn't want to affect her
like that is huge his assumptions about
who he's related to and why he thinks
they're gone is also a signifier of how
very isolated both Mito and gone are
Mito would have been left alone when
gone left the island an almost perfect
repeat of king leaving the poor woman
has lost two of those most important to
her to the hunter exam despite knowing
they would leave and Gon's grandmother
lost both her children the comic relief
between gongs grandmother and Mito is
wonderful and provides some welcome
relief to what could have been a very
sad and heavy episode the combination of
comedy and sadness means we land in that
crying waifu land of poignant stepping
away from all the lovey-dovey poignant
pretty stuff for a moment can we just
enjoy for a moment that God has a boom
box boom and a magical nen box one that
fell apart when he said her and allowed
him to hear his father's voice for the
first time an incredibly important
moment that I think is going to push us
explosively into the next are
understanding who King is changes the
end credits of the series and was
particularly important this episode
because now I could see that each of the
people or things in the end credits show
something important to the character
they're where guns hunting ding of
course killer wants to overcome his fear
of alumi karateka is hunting the Phantom
troupe and Lee audio is hunting
knowledge a great way to end the episode
with that piece of knowledge and a great
way to win this episode so that's it for
me I hope you've enjoyed this delve into
the bold and the beautiful also known as
the Schwing and the pretty if you want
to see more stuff you should look at
this
maybe this too and over
service and and if you really wanted to
chat come hang out on the discord or
click the thing here or maybe click
another thing ie